hi Sarah so I'd like to address your
question which has been put to me in a
number of different ways by a number of
different people and that is after
President Obama's Cairo speech about 18
months ago the one that was put the new
beginnings speech how can us Muslim
relations move forward you know what I'd
say I'd say that if we're going to be
realistic many of the policies that
president obama forward in the new
beginnings have not translated into your
policy and before you engage the the
muslim community to ask them to actually
contribute to what can happen moving
this relationship forward as well as the
Americans themselves let's look at the
reality on the ground you can only
change the dynamic and engage once you
understand the reality the reality is
that the global citizens the normal
people in America and rest of the world
from American non Muslims and Muslims
and then Muslims and non-muslims in the
rest of the countries they've done an
incredible amount the good world has
been shown from these people has been
incredible they've been working on
interfaith they've been working together
showing unity showing crust and doing
the kind of thing that is expected from
good people the problem is at the
political level and certainly from
President Obama's own personal
administration has been a number of
failings what can't be hidden is like
Guantanamo has still not been closed the
WikiLeaks disaster that has been
uncovered in Iraq has happened under his
watch the israeli-palestinian situation
seems as far away from a solution as it
was in the beginning despite the
enthusiasm and the concern that
President Obama respectfully showed it
and that in his credit but the reality
is from little points of view we haven't
seen enough clearly actions that go
against the very grain of his original
beginning speech the continual killing
of murder and murder indeed of innocent
civilians in Pakistan and Afghanistan
and the continuation of these two unjust
wars are not going to help anything
neither America neither the rest of the
world in this particular engagement my
answer to you is that the global
citizens aren't doing what they can we
are doing what I can myself my name is
ELISA I went with the first ethical
charitable trust in England and we are
encouraging our fellow Muslims to engage
in their society civic engagement to get
involved politically to get involved
socially activism to actually represent
themselves in the light of true
Britishness I either they are one with
their surroundings and that they are not
to be separated just on the basis of
their religion no malice see that's real
engagement there are many many other
people around the world that are doing
that Obama addressed the situation of
the u.s. versus the Muslim world the
reality is now is that he's losing the
US Muslim Americans within it within his
own country the recent kind of problems
have shown that and it's his actions
unfortunately on the international
political level that would ultimately
judge that the rising from people the
rise of the right wing and again the
glenn beck's and the syrup aliens and
the tea parties and all these kind of
craziness which is happening this
insanity has come our poor leadership
the leadership that we see are actually
paying for right wing votes and this
weekend we can see that there are still
good people that are fighting back there
are still good people that want to try
and restore sanity like Jon Stewart and
Israeli this is being recorded on the
eve of that rally so I would say that
we're doing what we can Muslims all
Muslims are doing what we possibly can
to improve the relationship but other
politicians know we need to put more
pressure upon them this is their
responsibility peace in the Middle East
is a cliche but it really is the mother
of all the problems once that's solved
honestly then we'll see a great result
after that I hope that that deals with
the question